a man threatening self-harm a person
with a gun these are just two scenarios
metro police face
every day but now more often than before
they're ending without force
in fact all this week we are looking
what changes metro police have made and
also what still needs work tonight the
i-team's david charns looking at
real-life scenarios our police are
learning from david
well denise the i-team got an exclusive
look at what real-life
training looks like for metro now this
isn't just for new officers but for
everybody on the force
and we do want to remind you what you
are about to see is all simulated
it may look like the real thing
but in this east valley warehouse these
guns don't have bullets
these tasers aren't able to fire welcome
to metro's reality-based training
where these tools are just as important
as the real life scenarios they're part
of
there's something that we're missing we
want to look and review it and get it
right and teach
our officers it's all to teach officers
de-escalation tactics for situations
where
force may have been the go-to answer
before
it's not about waiting for something
where you have this moment of crisis and
you act
acting in moments of crisis we don't use
any virtual reality here like this case
how do you communicate somebody who's
live on a farm but stressed out
officers are responding to a man who
accidentally fired his gun
tell me exactly what you're gonna do now
i'm so scared dude hopefully
they tell them hey take your finger off
the trigger it's gonna be okay
this time it ends with the suspect shot
anytime our officers
fired somebody and strike somebody it's
a big deal or we hurt somebody
it's a big deal to us these trainings
are something metro has done for years
and data shows it seems to be working
last year the department saw a quarter
reduction in officer officer-involved
shootings from the year before
fatal officer-involved shootings dropped
from 12 in 2018
to four last year metro's top brass says
their ongoing discussions about
change are working being progressive
means that you're constantly trying to
stay ahead
of these horrible things that are
happening across the country
that included the may in custody death
of george floyd
floyd's death then became a real life
scenario brought back to the classroom
we watch what happened in minnesota it
breaks our hearts it makes us angry all
those feelings
and i think it's even more so because
that man had a badge on
as much as it's nice to hear that metro
has learned from
you know the the lynching of george
floyd i have to kind of question like
when did that happen was it when they
were
shooting pepper balls at peaceful
protesters
wesley jewell works with the aclu of
nevada he says metro has come a long way
but training is just the start training
is the new
thoughts and prayers for police
departments it's not enough we need to
meaningfully regulate their interactions
with the community
metro says those interactions are now
reviewed and scrutinized
to stop the next incident before it
starts
we're continually looking at how to get
better
now we did ask metro about its policies
following floyd's death they say they
have specific rules about blocking a
person's air airflow during an arrest
and they say that policy was in place
well before
floyd's death back in may i'm david
charns 8 news now